[Music]
if that sounds familiar it's probably
because you've heard it taking Tick Tock
by storm
yeah it's called Natsu nachu from the
Indian film rrr in just weeks into the
new year the movie and the song are
becoming award season gold I am grateful
to the universe grateful to everyone who
made this possible yep the film's
composer mm caravani couldn't Express
his gratitude enough after taking home
the Golden Globe for best original song
what did that mean when they opened that
envelope and you hear your name Brad it
felt like OMG oh my god really come on
well yeah what else can I say
it's a dream coming true in winning that
award means he beats some of Hollywood's
biggest artists we're calling him Taylor
the pop diva Slayer yes Taylor Swift
Lady Gaga
Rihanna you beat them all all of them
are my favorites yes yeah what what do
you want to say to them
I want to say to them
that I am not your contender
I am your family now
[Music]
I belong to you as for if mm's aware of
his songs making its rounds on the
internet he said this about its viral
success I feel very much I mean I feel
amused thrilled excited
and I I feel I'm I am very grateful to
to the universe is a song of Celebration
uh which portrays lots of stamina energy
and happiness
it's it's packed with ethnic beats uh
and grooves
so it's all about celebration and the
critic's choice is
RR
the film now two Critics Choice Awards
one for best foreign language film my
mother rajanandani she
she thought school education was
overrated and she encouraged my
creativity to my motherland India Bharat
Mera Bharat Mahan thank you
and the second best song
[Music]
rrr which stands for Rise War revolts
tells the story of two men fighting
against the British rule in India rrr is
a Indian production tells about a tale
between two friends the bond
the bridge the Betrayal
and love
it's about patriotism lots of packed
with emotions action scenes and music
so this is the for the first time
it has bagged the attention and Applause
of international
audience I'm very happy for that it's
one of India's most expensive films and
it's even getting the attention of
Hollywood celebs check out mm and James
Cameron at critic's Choice alongside the
photo mm tweeted quote the gray James
Cameron has watched rrr twice and gave
feedback on my score while we celebrate
the success of Natsu Natsu and RR we'll
be playing this on repeat
foreign
[Music]